this is a really big day I am honored I
would like to thank the Academy the
Southern Poverty Law Center has named a
video I did for Prager University in
which I attacked the alt-right the most
egregious Prager u video of all time
meanwhile the left is breathlessly
reporting frivolous nonsense we will
analyze some of that but only later in
the show because first and I'm also
honored to have this actor and comedian
Tom Arnold will stop by to talk about
his new show on Vice which focuses on
that strangely elusive Russian golden
showers tape Democrats have insisted
they have on Donald Trump we will
discuss how the Democrats are running on
smoke and mirrors I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
all right let's get right into it we we
have Tom here vice is doing a new show
delving into the issue Americans really
care about most whether there is a video
of Russian hookers urinating on a bed in
donald trump's hotel room to discuss the
show we have brought the host here
himself you know Tom Arnold before we
get to Tom I've got to advertise a
little bit make a little money honey I
got to talk about movement sunglasses I
you know that I love movement and by the
way I'm a sunglasses aficionado I always
it's a one thing I'll buy expensive
because you wear them all the time and
they really matter they affect how you
see the world and because I'm Italians
obviously we were expensive sunglasses
you don't need to buy expensive
sunglasses to get really really high
quality or movement has the answer you
know look you can buy a pair of 200 $300
sunglasses you feel like you got ripped
off you could lose them on the airplane
or something these guys at movement who
have totally revolutionized the watch
industry they said we're gonna make
quality trendy sunglasses at a fair
price they aren't plastic they're
acetate you can get them polarized which
I did they're really nice the hide is
the the model that I got and they're
they're beautiful and they work really
well they start at just 70 bucks these
are my go-to shades they are just as
high quality as the much more expensive
ones and they're they're really really
good I really like them I got the the
tortoise whiskey shade which looks very
cool makes me look like a real hipster
it transfers from my rachel maddow look
very well into the sunglass moisture
there and they handle my they handle
moisture wonderfully they were really
really yeah high quality premium acetate
frames no cheap plastic here get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com / co f f/a
co v fe fe MVM t.com / co f f/a co v fe
fe you know movement for the watch
industry now you can see how the
revolutionising sunglasses join the
movement Tom Arnold has already joined
the movement in that ad read he is an
actor in a comedian you know Tom you've
seen him alongside Arnold Schwarzenegger
in the movie True Lies and a million
other things you've seen him alongside
ex-wife Roseanne Barr probably recently
in the news and in a bunch of other
movies and TV shows Tom is now doing a
show with Vice land in which he gets
down to the real important issues facing
the country
that elusive golden showers tape from
the long discredited democrat funded
steel dossier here is the trailer grab
them by the place talking about
sixteen-year-old girls in their
underwear here okay
viewing racial slurs list of celebrity
apprentice don't worry tom arnold is on
it and I'm Tom Arnold
tombé here that was strange
well my here's my first question yes
with many things than the broom closet
of the ben shapiro show yeah fix it in
post right my first question for you
this is a show as people will have seen
now in post-production yeah this is let
me explain something to you young man a
golden shower is there's a difference
between a golden shower and a an ulcer
to feed a hooker and a model so so that
you that's a red herring sir okay there
was no golden shower there was a model
urinating on a bed because because
Donald Trump doesn't like Barack Obama
would you agree that Donald Trump
doesn't like Barack Obama agree that a
half the people in this room don't like
Barack Obama because we're very lucky to
have Vice joining us today to be filming
this report of the show right usually
it's a hundred percent of the people in
the room but have you ever had a sub
what urinate on the bed because you
don't like Barack Obama dude is that the
level of dislike from Brock Obama that
you have will it never occurred to me
that my level of dislike for Barack
Obama was such that I would even vote
for Mitt Romney to get rid of Barack
Obama well that's interesting my that's
my first question
this whole thing is about this Terry we
just interviewed I just interviewed
David cord yeah and because of him and
his dang of tape recording having that
waiter tape record bit Robbie we could
be in the second term of that Romney's
presidency right now that's true that is
your right and once were dating David
core David corn gave us Donald Trump he
kept us down from do you have the tape
do you have the Russia urination on the
bed Barack Obama tape I'm a hundred
percent sure it exists how are you sure
you don't have it yourself I don't have
it myself but I've also shared the steel
dossier is a hundred percent real okay
but even Democrats now we're saying that
steel dossier is I mean we know
demonstrably some of it is first of all
can we agree on what they Democrats are
idiots
well do we agree that not all of them
but you know right they got all the
cameras go on and Republicans aren't
morons can we agree with that I can
agree with the first part more you
saying already say sup about Donald
Trump I love the way you talk about him
you talk about him like a second grader
talks about Santa Claus two toddlers
you're like God
come on he doesn't go to every house on
Christmas Eve that's a that's a story
yeah he's a story so but yet I'm gonna
save at all the trouble he is outside of
Macy's telling everyone he goes to every
house of Christmas Eve he truly does -
he's that crazy well he has been giving
us wonderful gift since he was
inaugurated I get in that way I think
he's like Donald like 40 this is my
question so you don't you don't have the
tape but you're sure it exists yeah why
lived in the Bosco Ritz
they do tape everything you do that of
course they do that goes without saying
and it's kind of funny how they do it
they brag about their technological
advancements at the Moscow Ritz and the
irony there is because they're recording
everything you're doing right but we
know you know that he went to a PP party
this summer before in in Las Vegas said
he went to a PP show and I have a
picture of him doing that the summer
before that do you so it's a cop Michael
Isikoff
yeah in their book there's a picture of
him doing that so the groundwork was
laid he went to a show where a woman
PETA to a champagne flute there's a
picture of him doing that the summer
before this but here's the thing Tom
you're Russian Roulettes the name of the
book you love books please read that I
will I really I really don't use words
yeah you do I know that's right that is
so funny the book you wrote with that
thank you very much so you're making a
waste of paper what trees are an organic
renewable resource I'm saving the
environment by printing that book
otherwise it will turn you have amazing
hair son stop it you're gonna make me
blush
yeah you make a lot of these claims that
the tape exists the Democrats have been
looking for this tape we know the
Democrats funded that steel dossier we
know a lot of it has been started I know
the Democrats really funded a lot of it
we know that both Republicans and
Democrats have used fusion GPS for
opposition research yes of course right
the steel dossier you say it's not
accurate the steel dossier I'm so
absolutely it's not accurate we know
that how do you how do you what's not
accurate okay give me something I'll go
through points my points okay so in the
steel dossier this is quoting from the
steel dossier the Russian regime has
been cultivating supporting assisting
Trump for at least five years aim
endorsed by Putin has been to encourage
splits and divisions in the Western
alliance can't be true what's going on
by the way what what about the new
this week with our alliances and the g7
and what's going on with Trump and
Canada the split is not true about that
well then surely with what Trudeau and
Trump in our lives and what's going on
with Germany is absolutely true all of
our allies we're not getting along with
them we're gonna be sunny North Korea
and indeed Boonton and China and not our
allies anymore
that's exactly what's happening brother
under the Obama administration our
allies paid far less for their
involvement in NATO Oh seriously
both Barack Obama and his predecessor
encouraged the our allies in NATO to
actually pay their fair share
so that's really what is about okay
that's that's good news to you no no
because so that is what's happening what
that is better they didn't say anything
about there's nothing steel talking
about oh they're gonna pay more money
those words you just read are happening
right now in real time well here--here's
okay here's some pretty strange ones so
here's another line from the steel
dossier okay the it alludes to the
existence of a Russian dossier or compra
Matt on Hillary Clinton is confirmed by
source be she or he confided in a
trusted compatriot than it had been
collated by Department K of the FSB for
many years except the Directorate K
which is an infamous part of Russian
intelligence doesn't do intelligence on
foreign leaders it that SVR does fapsi
does but not director it K so it just
doesn't add up
okay sure what you just said but they
got some on Hillary get it because
dinner what I should be president
anymore
that means nothing they're living case
away the first thing you read is
absolutely true because there is
everything you said so you're saying
that Russia predicted in 2011 that
Donald Trump could become the president
of United States Russia Vladimir Putin
being the only person on earth who
predicted that Donald Trump could be the
president of United States
no Donald with Donald Trump called said
that brocco bomb was not born here he
started the birther campaign in 2011
people rose up and supported him did
anybody seriously think that he would
become the president 2011 I know in 2013
but Vladimir Putin called his room in
the in Moscow ritz-carlton and he Donald
Trump put that call at a speakerphone
and that some people I know that were
with the Miss Universe contest and he
said to everybody I want you to be the
president we will support your date way
we can't but this is the problem Tom you
hear all the time well he is the
president and this is happening but so
yeah that's been staying in the moment
here but here's the problem the question
has been we have these tapes that was
what we don't know someone has works
he just cited with he gave stuff to
North Korea that's just we said ok don't
war war exercises what is the war game
scheduled we're games no but you heard
his words you heard his word for Santa
Claus like Santa didn't really do that
when is that war game scheduled for it's
not scheduled I know you're you're being
practical you should be the president
but you're not for real I got the German
for president oh he is out of his mind I
know first of all I know him I've been
to the Playboy Mansion with him I was at
the creepy guy I brought in 30 years I
wish you're president you're a smart kid
you know I'm glad you're around you know
but hit but he's insane okay and but I
wonder is we always hear his stupid he's
insane from people who know him he's
exactly as it was 30 years ago but he
keeps being successful and this is my
real question he gave way that is he
successful we are losing everything he
everyday we we risk losing everything
there's people propping him up I'm not
saying you I'm saying you're like oh no
what he really means no he is that
batshit crazy okay but look at the the
actual facts on the ground he's a
straight-up racist looking at his
policies lewdness fazio the totality is
racist he they're ripping people from
the mothers children from their mothers
at the borders it's not it's a policy
reporting illegal aliens no no no no but
there's a cruelty to it but it's Michael
but what's the racist Michael there's a
great season so it's always brown people
I'm telling you grasping white people
are crossing the border from Mexico
that's true but if it were white people
crossing the borders as it wouldn't be
deported we shouldn't enforce
immigration I'm telling you
something about it I'm telling you is
there countries I'm telling you there is
a difference there is a difference or
it's just some lovely Machado I get I
get what you're doing the point is that
I know the guy - I spent time with the
guy it is different you there's no
reason to rip babies from their mothers
period well anywhere anywhere that
there's no so you're saying you know are
you a father
no there's different you that's a
different that's right Harry that's
different this different house that we
have it does really or Americans we
don't do that we're better than that we
don't enforce our immigration don't know
because we have humanity there are ways
to do things and we're better than that
but don't you think Morgan's have a
right to determine who gets to come in
there yes that's right we do mid crimes
yeah we can do it the American Way
because we're better than that's the
American Way we hit with humanity and
with respect
so you're saying don't deport illegal
aliens no I've said you do you
absolutely do so you do it the right way
the American Way and they treat people
with respect and you treat people well
and you don't rip people apart and you
don't use that you know that's how you
know that's how you're talking about
those images of the kids and the cages
and all that kind of so no I'm talking
about literally what they're doing right
but Barack Barack of all there we are
you a father all right well it's a big
country and it's a wise man who knows
who his father is but none that I know
of
all right do I say you're not fine well
if you were just a man if you were and I
have imagined your son being taken from
you if you could imagine that feeling
yeah I don't want my son to cross
illegally into another country - okay
and I wouldn't do it on his behalf
no but you don't understand what's your
parent you'll understand there's
something inside of you but I'm not
going to another country so that I don't
need to be disrespectful of you or you
know what you're talking about okay
until your parrot
what's your parent you know you you
can't even imagine it's always who
opposed illegal immigration yeah there's
you it's you absolutely opposed there's
just a humane way of doing things do you
think that the people who voted for
Donald Trump half the country that
they're racist deplorable irredeemable
know
that would be as bad as being you and
say oh it's about you they get blankets
sabers like oh you can't deport illegal
aliens no you humanity you have to have
humanity especially when you have to
think about where the earth is one
planet okay do you believe in God
Francis yes okay then take a step back
if you believe in God so you think God
is like deport people deport me w
manatee no humanity Michael dolls no
people old no Betty these are the boss
the God is God is God of perfect justice
and perfect mercy which is very
difficult for us but we know from Saint
Paul's epistles that the civil authority
is endowed with a right to enforce the
law isn't that right that's first of all
Jewish mercy tell me about the mercy at
the border of taking babies from their
mothers intentionally to be punitive to
be punitive and these mothers are
escaping domestic violence to get to
America the land of the free the home of
the brave just to get an opportunity to
save their children's lives and tell me
about Jesus and I saw the Jesus
documentary that Mark Burnett made or
the the base you want to read the book
it's a good book well I've read this
chapter the first chapter or the first
part do you wonder what Jesus think
about all this we're real what would
Jesus think about the civil government
enforcing the law well I'll take it from
his apostle that it is perfectly right
for the civil government to afford
enforce the law and what do you think
about these money guys these billions
the well they were I don't know how many
billionaires there were at the time he
did let's talk with us for you this for
this this talk with your heart for a
second yeah baby speed yank from there
both it just says is there not a better
way to do this what is the better way
first of all we're not we're not
deporting little babies and said nobody
mother's day the babies go to Honduras
but the mothers stay in America that's
not what help babies go to Chicago Widow
tell what the mothers where they are
it's not except listen we could do
better yeah we could do better the most
charitable immigration regime in the
entire we have the hi no no we go
you run this better than they do down
there you know where that monitor is you
got a better crew here people listen you
don't know what they're doing either
yeah we we apprehend over a thousand
people a day crossing illegal into this
country at the border and three years we
bred a horrible meat packing plant
better they don't know what they're
doing yet let's say they just change the
policy they don't have things set up
they don't have housing set up we knew
we had hog refinment there are you don't
know I'm telling you haven't been there
I'm telling you I've the people down
there I've been day I don't know there's
not about setting up tents it's a
freaking hundred degrees in here
do they go to heaven set up Tom do you
know what makes that so hard what we
apprehend a thousand people they're
great they're human beings whole lot
they're human beasts we would not allow
our port to cattle to be treated like
this right now because legally you can't
you have to have certain kind of
facilities right now they just say well
we on how many how many people that we
apprehend at the border every day do we
just send right back to their country as
as probably we should you know how many
people we do that do you ever have zero
people do it for a second and I know the
bleeding heart liberals I know it could
be [ __ ] I know they're way over the
[ __ ] top but for a second and can you
not think that way could you think it
would be going against rub for a second
can you die can you not go I think
Americans have a right to to the their
own democratically enacted laws by
partisan laws to decide who comes in and
who comes out we have the highest
highest rates of immigration until
recently because it's dropped under
under Donald Trump but we have the
highest percentage of foreign-born
population in American history since
1890 under the best of circumstances
assimilation is difficult under these
sort of circumstances it's virtually
impossible 80 percent of women and girls
who cross the border you know I think
about this we hated Italians everybody
hated Italians Americans did not want to
tell us here it was like dodo they were
stored they were the scum of the earth
you probably don't remember this your
parents your grandparents to tell you
about this did not what they did not
want to tell you is here and just read
this right oh you've read books
and they were scored if they were they
were looked down upon and it was awful
Tom it was awful but according to
Amnesty International and the Huffington
Post not exactly right-wing outlets
between 60 and 80 percent of women and
girls who crossed the border illegally
raped and sexually assaulted
what is compassionate or merciful or
humanitarian about encouraging a regime
encouraging the human traffickers who
bring those women and girls across the
border and rape them along the way it's
a red herring
it's a red herring 16 80 percent is red
herring it's a reddit uart but it's what
we do when they get to the border to rip
their children apart we need to take
that that's our policy to scare them to
go back we're gonna take your children
for them Tom I don't I don't I think
there's a federal statute to rip
children away fro there do it it's
policy you will you look at to it for me
you do something about it with me I if
it's a we we do if if there's a federal
policy traditions run away from there
okay mothers take the children away for
their parents too there has been
suicides of the parents because they
could find their children well there
when people do get to the border they do
have to be processed there they're okay
and I certainly true there's a national
policy there's a form of local child
that was taken from her mother yesterday
will you at least investigate this with
it horrible things happen because of
illegal immigration okay so stop illegal
immigration okay so you're not denied is
true I know I'm I'm actually saying it's
much worse than you are saying it is I'm
saying
illegal immigration causes many many
more problems than you're saying it is
which is why we need to cut off all
incentives for it and enforce our
immigration laws and have the we could
do it we could do better
I'd well it's easy to say these slogans
right it's and it's easy for this
innuendo this is the question that I
want to get to because right now the
economy's going gangbusters it's doing
better than it ever has before rich
people for corporations for is you know
whatever everybody just got a tax cut
the economy's don't know very well come
on this you know they're faster than the
doing very well stock you say
but I don't know nevertheless very much
your feelings yeah yeah yeah
historically your feelings these people
you still gotta care about people but
but this is reality this is reality is
that your reality but you know you're
responsible but there's only one reality
time no no no that's not true
if you have to accept there are there
are other realities if you think your
reality is the only one you're for I
think we've explained the
democrat-republican device well there's
one big rub your you'd defend a guy
who's is a complete alternate reality
Donald truck lies everyday 50 times day
and then you explain it for us well
first of all I'll explain that
explaining right after I make a little
bit of money we got to talk about thrive
market baby thrive is a wonderful
marketplace I want to thank them for
being a great sponsor they have great
savings on all the products you need to
live a healthy life it's a revolutionary
online marketplace on a mission to make
healthy living easy and affordable for
everyone you can shop for thousands of
the best-selling non-gmo foods and
natural this is Bridget this is bridging
the plan a divide it is so good I always
use their olive oil especially it's
really high-end they can curate it they
make the choices soil much easier to
make the trails are great they're really
really good a highly curated catalogue
you know you might only find three to
four options for each product it's
because they are the best more than 70%
of the Thrive catalogue cannot be found
on amazon largest retailer in the
country that sells exclusively non-gmo
groceries and right now i'm gonna give
you free food get $60 of free organic
groceries plus free shipping and a
30-day trial here's how it works users
will get $20 off their first three
orders of forty-nine dollars or more
plus free shipping you're gonna want to
buy a lot more than that though most
shoppers spend more than 49 on our side
anyway I certainly do
do the math you spend $49 Thrive
automatically gives you back 20 bucks so
your total purchase is just 30 you get
this deal three times in a row thrive
market calm slash michael mi CH AE l to
get $60 of free groceries don't say I
never did nothing for you thrive market
calm slash Michael
all right Tom back to reality this
explains me because I've never seen this
that Trump you're in tape right
Democrats it seems to me they are
distracting from all of the good things
that are happening in this country with
innuendo and implications and the
fantasies of other realities that are
fantasies well it is true that we are
far apart because we I guess we feel
like you're totally over here with the
fantasy the Donald Trump is infallible
and everything isn't what have I ever
said he said what okay gimme the bill
okay Dave one thing that he's absolutely
lied about that he well I think Donald
Trump talks like a New Yorker so I'll
give you a nice gives even out that well
no it but it really ok give me the
example so the example is this Donald
Trump says we have you know oh we had
the biggest crowds ever for this we had
60,000 people at such and such a rally
now in reality maybe the rally only had
30 or 40 thousand people I'm willing to
acknowledge that the way New Yorkers
talk is a little hyperbolic he goes out
he says you know this is the most
tremendous thing that's ever happened in
the history of the world maybe it's not
the most tremendous thing that's ever
happened but it's it's a hyperbole and
it leads into an exuberance I don't
think that's the kind of lie is saying
if you like your doctor you can keep
your doctor which the former press like
that's a terror three thousand lies you
don't think that man is straight-up lied
to the American people what is he lied
about everything he is like what he said
my rich Reds are really bad about this
tax break
god help ya it it raised taxes on the up
on people in New York and Los Angeles on
me and on people in the up higher
highest income bracket raise taxes on
them yeah it did but all the truth
because he hates me all the trillions of
dollars
you should have coming back into this
country yeah there are over we have
repatriated money from the skies of
trillions rated jobs as well you know
there's my family will not benefit they
have not got a better to real time this
family vodka Jared they will not benefit
from working in my administration
whatever they benefit eighty two million
dollars last year that family benefited
well the truck yeah the Trump
Organization is still in operation sure
the Trump Organization
making her smile a personally made how
much how much money how much money did
Barack Obama have going into the
presidency and leaving the president
okay tanea more like 3 billion Barack
Obama was a freaking president of the
United Sates wasn't a small advise a
senior advisor how much okay Louis is
how many times Barack Obama golf and how
many times have you complained about it
I don't mind oh you never complain about
the go get my did Donald Trump but hey
Joseph said I will never go he's golf
ten times more do you ever call him out
on his how many times he calls other
people oh this is actually getting to
the central point of your TV show and my
criticism of the I don't trust him
negotiating anything for us
I think the Donald Trump is a Russian
asset I don't think he knows it what's
your evidence I don't think he does it
what's your evidence he is in love with
Putin he has it he is a Putin does have
something on him what he doesn't know
but he won't let us investigate he won't
let us follow through they battled in
our election he said every time they
metal in the election they spent
$100,000 on Facebook ads few not
adjusted to our own intelligence what
intelligence are you referring to
because I'm citing 200,000 oh okay you
aren't privy to it because it's the NSA
the CIA and the FBI they've shared all
that with but a metal specifically
because it's easy to accept I'm not
privy to it either I can tell you and
they a higher percent certainty I can
share that with the field an IKE I can
tell you how the Russians meddled in the
Alliance by the way I think they fixed
the election for Delta it's not like
they just spent a hundred thousand think
thinks he's an illegitimate president
and he does it and that's why he's
fighting this he says he is not the
president he doesn't deserve to be the
president Tom it's in he is not the
president he's an illegitimate president
I know everything he accused Barack
Obama that's him he's not the president
he took all our health insurance away
how he did that yeah Donald say that's
another thing he is trying to take
people's health insurance away just
because Barack Obama gave it to that Tom
I liked my doctor and I didn't get to
Kaiba done you want to do I quit my
place he's gonna do it again is it 18
and dumb folks could make sure he
doesn't stop him Tom he's not protecting
our our ballot boxes are voting machines
when you're talking about Russia do it
again Donald
listen the Senate had a hearing
yesterday and they're freaked out about
it because he's not doing anything about
it
that bothers me bori is a basic tenant
of our vegetable that's why Republicans
are trying to protect the integrity of
the Bella bond why did they show up for
that Senate hearing Republican centers
did not show up where is their beholding
Donald Trump hey take your time if you
want to protect the integrity of the
ballot box do you think that people
should have to show an ID to vote I
think you should protect us from Russia
number one not from Americans protect us
from outside Thor listen to John McCain
John McCain usually not great advice
it's John McCain really really I'll take
John McCain over and over Donald Trump
there any of these guys I know the
players much prefer John McCain to
conservative Republicans that's true
that's very true anybody if you if
you're not taking John McCain as a
patriot a manager stood up there yeah
yeah but I don't like his political
views
really I don't be I think he wanted to
go out with the go get stuffing guy says
you know here's the lied the the versus
outside forces it's John McCain it got
its proved it every time better than you
or me or Donald Trump who's put himself
on the line for this country it's John
McCain okay yeah forget long he served
yes for beyond served admirably they can
say gage for five years yeah extremely
Admiral okay but that doesn't mean that
his political views have politics I'm
talking about
he's an American patriot that put
yourself on the light and this is what
it's like because they're gonna screw
around with art and you're about that oh
don't you want to take away votes oh you
gotta show it I want to take away ah I'm
talking about Russian I want it out of
our election but Tom what are you doing
to keep the Belvoir like sure you want
to keep people of color for Bodie by
short IDs or will it be when if I ever
gets murders white people to vote are
they heard for Russians to vote no Tom
that is a real accusation is black
people [ __ ] well you see what it what
that you you see how many people can't
vote you said it okay so who do you got
what to vote
Americans I don't want Russia's to vote
well really I don't want Democrats to
vote for right okay
she has the right to vote everybody
markets voting stop Russians were voting
Tom I want people who have the right to
vote to be able to vote and I want
people who don't have the right to vote
to not be a bit slight but it's such a
stupid thing like two people out of a
billion fed vote more than once and
that's you're making a big deal you
think there are two Illig yeah I think
that's stupid over there
stop Russians from voting put your
energies to that this is an argument you
know there's many all you tried try to
get Democrats so they can't vote so you
gear he just want to suppress black
people and Republicans votes that's what
you do you know that's a big accusation
just say it's an absolute fact that you
do it what is your evidence not facts
look at facts how many 20 Tom it's a
fact look at Ohio how many people you
stop foreboding there are people of
color because they are Democrats you're
right
Tom you're just saying things that are
fantasies no no like I've seen their
facts why don't you stop Russia's voting
put your be in America political I think
okay I don't think a lot of Russian
nationals voted in our last election I
don't think they were here campaigning
or here pretending they were lobbying
Hillary Clinton to even Fox disprove
that disprove luck the Chevy Shepard
Smith I'll send you the clip with it
what is that is it read Harry what did
right here you know that Tom you can go
that you can interrupt and distract and
use profanity all you want well we will
edit it sorry but Tom you can distract
and you can change the subject and you
can interrupt all you want that doesn't
change judicial jobs bill on is he's a
source D the Christopher steel as
opposed to fly down to view oh he is
sourced well there are those who's in
the room for the PP stuff so there's a
steel dossier because we still go see it
paid for by Democrats and lied about by
Democrat elide about by demo what do you
they lied they lied about their
involvement in it but it's also an
election it's all true though but we
know that some appear in this group we
know that we know that it's been
disproved by keep going
it's a coffin cord have proved it and I
have a guest that's great for you and
keep them really prove it so bloody
Christopher seals a hero this guy came
to the aid of the United States working
for an interloper interfering in our
elections that's why they're called
allies we called out you know our
greatest allies so who do you think our
allies are Jean Kim eel or whatever yeah
little rocket me yeah I you know
seriously who D their allies are I'm our
allies or our allies and allies David oh
I suppose Italy I'll use my own heritage
a moment France really likes us now the
French premier Emmanuel macron loves
Donald dramati also said drop don't be
giving stay this week a buddy back
Israel is an ally of ours they're very
happy with us now because Barack Obama
turned on our news he'd ever seen he
what do you dog it here because what is
it about that guy what is it that you
guys feel you get blamed stuff on it he
what is see what's different is a
terrible terrible president how much the
country immensely yeah that's why I keep
talking about I think there's something
else about him there's something about
him a far left wing Democrat who damaged
the country who destroyed 1/6 of you
think about what the worst economic
recovery since you're aware with the way
he took over will you give it that did
you know facts would you remember the
economy there was a there was a
financial crisis it was almost a
depression we've been a to war give him
that give it well you know no give of
that it is true that the vast majority
of deaths American soldier deaths in
Afghanistan occurred under Barack
Obama's watch it also created more come
on come on you're smart kid
I give of this too he was the first
black American president you remember
that that's a big deal this country what
you're saying is the people are racist
but this country had slavery on him give
a bet we bid through a lot of this
company had slit there we rode so big
acknowledge that that's a big deal and
we went through Jim Crow we feel it
don't overlook who denies they don't
acknowledge that that we went through a
lot so it was a big deal for all of us
then when he was elected a college
been a good president take a moment did
you see like it you talk like that is a
terrible president no no do not take a
beat ago you know that's a big deal and
he did those huge God to take just one
side ago the the economy is the crapper
he was he was awful around the board a
lot of Americans repeatedly he was
terrible on foreign affairs he was
terrible and domestic of that's a very
sad thing that the first thigh President
was so awful you need to take a beat you
need to take a beat you take a beat all
right I'm gonna take a beat and do one
last ad and then we'll get back into the
last last segment of this he had for
your sponsors oh yeah this from
Skillshare Skillshare is really good
they've been with us since the beginning
we love them skill sure is an online
learning platform with over 20,000
classes in business design technology
and more so you might think you know
that innuendo is enough but it's not you
need to you need to learn facts through
skill share you can take classes in
social media marketing illustration data
science mobile photography creative
writing you name it they've got it
whether you were trying to deepen your
professional skill set start a side
hustle or just explore a new passion
skill share is there to keep you
learning and thriving
I really like them I've taken one on
that you can do one on hypnosis
I'm afterward you know they're really
good time management is good I'm not
good on time management today because
we're running a little late on the show
but join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer for just my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for just 99 cents that's right
the Michael Doyle show listeners get two
months of unlimited access to over
20,000 classes for just 99 cents
Skillshare comm / michael again go to
Skillshare comm / michael mi CH AE l to
start your two months now Skillshare
comm slash michael my final point for
this segment tom do you have good
sponsors they are wonderful spawn
they're really good so my final point on
this is all that we've heard about we
don't see the the left making TV shows
about the terrible economy or TV shows
about the terrible foreign affairs or
the TV shows about all the terrible
oppression going on in the country
because they couldn't none of that is
happening all we're seeing shows on our
stormy Daniels the porn star and the the
elusive tapes from a long discredited
dossier and the business and than that
we're you know and and oh I heard he
said a bad word on tape or this or that
isn't that just because Democrats are
distracting from how everything is going
tickety-boo
you know I guess we're all just going
about our business you guys are our
baking shows you know you guys are hit
the save beat to your you just said
going about but we're not making up
stories well why don't you're pretending
they don't exist you're just going over
you're just kind of going up here there
are a lot of tongues show me that show
me the tape of the Russian models
urinating on the bed and okay it's real
show me the tape right now and lo I
gotta savor it it's gonna be on my show
but you have so now you're saying you do
have the tape I've said I play no buts
do you have that I'd say that I'd say
you will see you've entrusted a cold us
means I'll tell you what you can see if
you don't think Trump says he had word
if you don't think Trump calls women all
kinds of Phil now you will see that it's
that we have the tape of Donald Trump
saying the N word do we have a can we
play it there are white use that word
today our country has lost a true
American original my friend and mentor
Robert C bird there are white senator
Byrd was a man of surpassing eloquence
and nobility I've seen a lot of white
might I'm gonna use that word senator
Byrd was a man of surpassing eloquence
and nobility today our country has lost
a true American original my friend and
mentor Robert seabird
guys was that Donald Trump who was that
Donald Trump or was that a former Senate
Majority Leader Robert Byrd the Democrat
whom Hillary Clinton referred to as her
great friend and mentor was that what I
think it was the demin to do the story
about this is most hilarious using the
n-word
he's Robert Verdi everybody's using it
you've never said the Edward I think I
read a beat packing plant Hey you
probably heard these words but you heard
he course I am 30 Iowa but so has it my
next-door neighbor's dog was named the
Edward bear like source are you gonna so
are you defending Donald Trump for
allegedly using a racial slur in alleged
video that nobody's seen are you
defending him now because everybody said
it yeah see gotta trip white here's him
say the n-word why of course he said
it's yours it's when you are a bird and
Hillary Clinton using and you yourself
say everybody's use these slurs you
really she's not the president so you
thank you yeah good lord do you feel
totally confident that he will not get
us in some sort of war I think he has
been incredible on Paris do you think he
will not get a civil war Michael I tell
you I've asked you serious you think
that one military soldier will die
because of it I've got know what's worse
happen all the time I mean we decide
them well the boys are Astana but I care
you know I don't think they get all do
you I've been to Afghanistan I've been
to Iraq I'm in all places I talked to
the families I do a lot of service work
of that area do you feel comfortable
telling the servicemen and women and
their families America that that guy has
gotten together enough do not risk the
lives of any man and woman well the
military risks their lives to defend the
country and the times Hannah a hundred
percent he's I am 100% confident that he
is a much more competent commander in
chief then we've seen in recent years
and certainly more so than Barack Obama
and 100% confident of that confident do
you feel he's confident yes I do I think
he's I think if you just look at how is
handling we know that Isis has been
utterly militarily demolished we're
seeing some progress being made on the
Korean situation it's the first inning
but it's being made that's pretty good
we're seeing our allies finally coming
around and cooperating with
international agreements we're seeing
countries like China who have violated
World Trade Organization trees for years
finally coming to the table and
negotiating we're seeing the IMF the
International Monetary Fund saying that
Donald Trump is responsible for the
surge in the global economy
I am totally confident in this president
shocking as it is
on his handling of foreign affairs
absolutely and I see no evidence to the
contrary
Feuer father you might take pause before
saying that I'm just telling I'm just
selling you how how are you guys
I would I would change I would say okay
I'm not gonna ignore those facts no no
it would be again but like the thing at
the border with the kids we take it away
from parents it would be more personal
but no change reality
it does change reality what's your
parent this reality changes Tom we have
actually hit on I've got to let you go
because I don't but this we have
actually hit on this the difference here
is I'm sitting here saying look there's
only this one reality that's happening
and you are literally saying right now
the personal is different than the
reality there's the subjective reality
there are multiple realities that
explains it that explains the show that
explains the Democrat campaigns for the
last two years more than that Tom
alright great to have you on thank you
so much I really and I really have to
say this because this is a very fun
conversation no Democrats no left
wingers ever come on my show and you
agreed to come on my show yeah great
you're great all right thank you very
much good luck to you all right we've
got to cut out of here before we get to
all the rest of the news if we have like
five minutes left go to daily wire calm
right now if you are a subscriber if
you're not go come on subscribe it's ten
bucks a month one hundred hours for an
annual membership you get me you get the
under Clavin sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the leftist tears
tumblr which Tom even Tom very
graciously drank out of so you've got to
get it it's fda-approved baby go over
there to daily we're calm we'll be right
back with the rest of the news
thank you
we're back okay we've got a lot to talk
about it was really nice to have time on
town by the way if you I don't want to
keep you hostage here right if you if
you want to hop that maybe I'll say yeah
order my stuff fish oil and my stuff
from your site website this is really
good this is the best ad reads that
we've ever gotten all right we've got to
get back into this so I said this was
we're talking about a lot of smoke and
mirrors here all of the emotivism all of
the innuendo not so much of the facts
listen to this from the Southern Poverty
Law Center you know because we could we
could just call all the news today
frivolous nonsense so we're focusing on
the Southern Poverty Law Center because
they've named my little old me my Prager
you video the most egregious Praeger
video of all time and it's the video in
which I attack the racists of the
alternative right but they're really
upset so here so what is the Southern
Poverty Law Center it's this massively
funded propaganda machine it's just this
leftist propaganda machine that's all it
is they you know they have this patina
of credibility because they have a
interesting sounding name
they are nothing they spent 10 million
dollars on fund raising in 2015
way more than they did on legal services
they transferred millions to offshore
tax havens they smeared the Family
Research Council which is a protrude
ischl family group a gunman who shot up
that council cited the influence of the
Southern Poverty Law Center in his
shooting there was mob violence at
Charles Murray's speech at Middlebury a
faculty member who was there cited
Southern Poverty Law Center again as
justification two years ago the FBI
totally stopped citing SPLC as a source
because it's so frivolous probably
shouldn't have nonprofit status its
founder is just a direct marketing guru
Morris Dees he was actually inducted
into the direct marketing Hall of Fame
real civil rights activists call him a
con man and but he's so effective
because all he does is rely on innuendo
just like we were talking about with Tom
it's that exact it's all well what do
you you don't think this exists what you
come on you know don't you really think
it's all just innuendo and so ironically
the Southern Poverty Law Center has
become a hate group
they're like against hate groups and
they become a hate group this is what
they wrote about my video from the
Southern Poverty Law Center quote the
most egregious of Praeger use videos in
trip odious opinion is what is the all
right
hosted by conservative internet talk
show host Michael Knowles the video
posits that is an alternative to
conservatism the OL tried is most
accurately compared with the left for
three reasons
the left and the alright are obsessed
with identity politics both focus on
group identity rather than the
individual and both the left and the old
right ultimately reject God the video
ends with Knowles declaring in other
words the old right has nothing in
common with conservatism and is in fact
much closer to the left ISM except of
course that the left is much much larger
that's all they wrote they said it's the
most egregious video and then they just
quote my video but they don't give any
evidence for why it's egregious they
don't give any argument for why it's
egregious they just they make a blanket
statement and then they just fill it in
with words they just try to distract
with frivolous nonsense right it's just
these distractions this wasn't don't you
think the economy's doing well don't
talk about the economy talk about this
imaginary video that where everyone's
been talking about well but don't you
think the Foreign Affairs no don't talk
about that don't to talk about right
it's all just distraction and by the way
this this is how Donald Trump won I know
it's become cliche to say this is how
Donald Trump won or this is how Donald
Trump won this is actually how he won
have you have you heard about the
ongoing saga of chick-fil-a so right
there was an article in The Huffington
Post it said if you really love LGBTQ
people you just can't keep eating
chick-fil-a the you can't so if you
really like gay people you can't eat
chicken sandwiches and this is what the
article said it said quote if you care
about queer people or yourself or you
yourself are queer you have absolutely
no business eating a chick-fil-a ever
it's really that straightforward and
they they deem them because chick-fil-a
donates to the Salvation Army which is
Christian and if it's Christian then
it's bad because it's not part of the
Pride movement or something the the
politicization of everything is so
tedious this this base innuendo that
everybody who doesn't agree with you is
a bigot or a racist or at this or that
you know it's so it's so tedious and
it's so divisive I mean even you know
the the
acronym LGBTQ is by definition divisive
right because it keeps dividing it says
LGBT QP LMNOP or so what it just keeps
going on and on and on to divide into
smaller and smaller interest groups
there isn't much of a common culture
anymore there isn't you don't see a lot
of common culture we don't watch the
same TV shows we do know it's I I'm
gonna watch Tom Arnold's show because
you know we had him on but I suspect a
lot of our audience probably isn't gonna
watch his show and it's not that we all
watch different things different movies
different knows different we read
different books if we read it all we
don't have a common religion we don't
even have a common traditional love of
country and this is what makes Donald
Trump appealing because Donald Trump
appeals to like the last remaining
things that unite us I'm not saying this
is a good thing or a bad thing I wish
there was more that United us but he
appeals to winning at least everybody
should want winning right he appeals to
good deals we're gonna get good deals
right okay that appeals to all of us
strength peace even football right he
you know when a football at least you
think that could unite all of us and
then that guy Colin Kaepernick tried to
make that that divisive as well and
tried to protest against the symbol of
America itself
he called them out on it people don't
want that this presidency ironically of
Donald Trump is essentially a call for
unity again in its own very brash
trumpian way you know he says things
like we all have the same blood of
patriots we all bleed the same blood of
patriots what made Barack Obama so
tedious it was all just about poking his
opponents all just about dividing and
dividing talking about why men should
use the little girl's bathroom and
painting the White House and rainbow
colors of light right you know it's so
just divisive writing off his countrymen
as bitter clingers I mean listen to that
I asked Tom I said are you calling half
the country racist and he said no and
then he called half the country racist
that you know when you write off your
countrymen as bitter clingers like
Barack Obama did or Hillary Clinton
writes them off is deplorable and
irredeemable that that people don't like
that don't that's not aspirational
that's not inspired that's just ugly and
bit crass and base and divisive and the
good news for us is as long
our political opponents on the Left keep
that up I think things are gonna look up
for us I mean there's a real
aspirational quality to this presidency
to this political moment bill kristol
the erstwhile Republican commentator and
conservative commentator he said the
Reagan years were aspirational and Trump
isn't he's missing it people are missing
this this is an aspirational moment of
coming together of succeeding of trying
to bring North Korea to the table and we
had a good first inning hopefully it
goes all the way to the end this is a
good moment and the left is relying
strictly on smoke and mirrors it is all
illusion and innuendo and smoke and
mirrors and we it's best just to smack
it down and to ignore it
all right that's that's the rest of our
show it's hard it's gonna be hard to
beat that one tom is the lively
personality but we won't be back
tomorrow we have another great guest and
then we've got some more more good stuff
planned in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you